avec plaisir et notre invité politique
ce matin sa fille et bonjour bon jeu
mais assez d'être la députée européenne
êtes conseiller spécial de marine le pen
on est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour
une interview en partenariat avec la
presse régionale représenté par eric
richard de la nouvelle république
bonjour eric bonjour en rien mon jour
philippe olivier bonjour c'est les
voiliers du rhum à parler des
législatives dans quelques minutes mais
on va des gens par les impôts puisque
emmanuel macron était dans le tarn hier
vous avez sans doute écouté son discours
dans son discours il a beaucoup cibler
les extrêmes les extrêmes ajoute de la
crise à la crise dit-il en vo visant
notamment qu répondez vous écouter on
voit bien que le président de la
république soir de son rôle il fait
campagne électorale il vient à la
rescousse deux des candidats de son camp
c'est pas le rôle du président
normalement il le fait en termes
extrêmement polémique ce qui est assez
dommageable et puis quand il nous parle
de de confusion ou de risque de 2,2 de
l'extrémisme jeu j'aurais envie de lui
dire qu' il est très mal placé moi je
pense que les images du stade de france
un certain nombre de choses un peu
chaotique que l'on vit devrait le
l'inspiré un peu plus d'humilité pour
extraire ces images de saab à écouter je
pense qu'il a je pense qu'il a il a dans
ses propos il ya beaucoup de violence
ont ces propos je pense que son
quinquennat son quinquennat précédent
mais même le quinquennat dans lequel
nous rentrons est marquée par une espèce
de violence endémique qui est assez
pénible juste un mot juste en un mot sur
le stade de france apprend on vénère
emmanuel macron mais puisque vous en
parlez les sénateurs ont poursuivi hier
leur jeudi sur un chercheur fiasco
l'organisation de la finale de la ligue
des champions didier lallement reconnu
en échec et on a appris que les vidéos
avaient été
les truites faute de réquisition à temps
alors on précise que le stade de france
à doit garder les vidéos sept jours et
les détruire automatiquement après mais
la faute de réquisition à temps ils ont
donc été détruites qu'en pensez vous
d'abord je pense que techniquement la
police a de quoi récupérer les vidéos
qui ont même qui ont été effacées de
disques durs parce qu'il ya des
possibilités techniques mais passons sur
cette question là qui est purement
technique l'aspect politique moi je
crois qu'on est pris par le syndrome de
cologne le sens noble de cologne c'est
quoi c'est le syndrome des personnes qui
ne veulent pas voir la réalité dès lors
qu'il s'agit d' immigration à cologne
avait eu un certain nombre d'agressions
sexuelles contre des femmes et on ne
voulait pas les voir pourquoi on voulait
pas les voir parce que c'était le fait
de migrants et là c'est pareil le stade
de france ce sont des hordes de mineurs
isolés ou des gentils cité qui sont
descendus et qui ont détroussé nos hôtes
britanniques
et bien c'est dommage qu'on n'ait pas
vous êtes journaliste c'est la réalité
madame tous les témoignages absolument
convergent toutes les vidéos qu'on a qui
sont des vidéos de deux smartphones
souvent et je c'est dommage d'ailleurs
qu'on n'est pas les vidéos officielles
parce que ça aurait confirmer mes dires
et voyez où vous êtes maître vous même
prise par le syndrome de cologne qu'est
ce qui vous permet de dire que que c'est
de l'immigration me dites vous et bien
moi je vous dis ce sont les images mais
vous même vous ne voulez pas le voir non
je vous demande qu'est ce qui vous
permet d'affirmer que ce sont des
mineurs isolés en plus bas la police qui
l'a dit un certain nombre de témoignages
les gens qui sont venus de la porte de
la chapelle mais si vous étiez
journaliste peut-être que vous lui aurez
vu
écoutez moi je crois qu'avec son bilan
il n'aurait pas dû rester mise
l'intérieur on a un bilan sécuritaire
qui est catastrophique et on voit bien
que monsieur macro n'en tire aucune
conséquence il garde le tandem darmanin
dupond moretti il aurait dû le changer
pour parvenir à ces discordes emmanuel
macron hier est et ce qu'il a dit sur
les et sam alors pour lui vous et jean
luc mélenchon c'est la même chose il
vous a mis un petit peu dans le même
c'est pareil c'est ce qu'il a dit hier
les extrêmes que dites vous c'est un peu
normal il est en campagne donc ils
essayent d'apparaître comme le candidat
du du bien face face aux méchants moi je
pense que au contraire on a on a un camp
en face de nous ce sont les
déconstructeurs les déconstructeurs d'en
haut monsieur macron avec des logique
mondialiste et des déconstructeurs d'en
bas monsieur mélenchon avec des logiques
internationale ihf donc vous voyez moi
je les met dans le même sac et il
appelle les électeurs à vaughan
mélenchon non mais il procède du même
esprit qui est de déconstruire la france
alors de manière différente la par le
biais d'un certain nombre de 10 des au
logis qui sont quand même sulfureuse
l'indigénisme le au kiss me le
racialisme c'est mélenchon et l'autre le
mondialisme le mercantilisme l'idée que
la france doit être diluée dans un grand
ensemble d'abord européiste et ensuite
mondiale
même nous nous sommes les partisans de
la france philippe rivière la différence
de la nuque baisse de la gauche que l'on
a beaucoup entendu dans cette dans cette
campagne le rassemblement national s'est
montré disons plutôt discret on a un
petit peu l'impression que votre parti
aborde ce scrutin un peu désabusé ou
tout au moins sans la volonté de
l'emporter qui était la vôtre au moins
d'avril non pas du tout on a la même
détermination de l'emporter mais on a
fait l'analyse qui est je crois une
analyse extrêmement justes et qu'une
élection initiative ses 570 cette
élection en réalité parce que chaque
circonscription est différente les
rapports de force qui sont différents
les candidats qui sont différents les
situations locales ils sont différentes
et on a fait une campagne de terrain
extrêmement active maintenant vous me
parlez du dynamisme de du ps moi
j'observe que la gauche au premier tour
de la présidentielle avait dépassé les
30% ils sont très largement en dessous
vraisemblablement dans les sondages cinq
points en dessous donc quand on nous
parle de l'indiana
dynamisme de nos peines moi j'aurais
tendance à dire que c'est une vision de
plateaux de télévision mais pas comme
dans les sondages et certains sondages
les donnent devant tout cas au coude à
coude avec la majorité présidentielle
mais quand même marine le pen elle est
arrivé deuxième de l'élection
présidentielle a fait plus de 41 % des
voix pourtant aujourd'hui celui qui
apparaît comme le principal opposant de
jean-luc mais de d'emmanuel macron c'est
jean luc mélenchon à ce que je n'avais
pas fait une erreur stratégique non on
nous disait ça vous savez en 2017 quand
il ya eu les élections
législatives et puis il ya eu la rentrée
parlementaire il met l'enfant faisait
son cirque fait son cirque l assemblée
avec des paquets de pâtes avec les gens
qui arrivent et en t-shirt de football
aa au parlement et en utiliser mais
c'est le meilleur opposant et puis
finalement quand il ya eu les élections
et bien c'est nous qui avons été
désignés par le corps électoral comme
les principaux opposants de monsieur
macron donc tous sommes très confiants
mais la haine georgette mélenchon il
fait campagne en dix ans et 10 mois
premier ministre c'est ce qu'il dit
depuis la fin du premier tour de la
présidentielle marine le pen elle a dit
non mais nous on est lucide emmanuel
macron aura une majorité parce que c'est
ce que veut la vème république
est-ce que du coup vous n'avez pas de
démotiver vos troupes est-ce que vous ne
vous êtes pas affaiblis avant même le
début du match
non nous on note pour caractéristique de
ne pas prendre les gens pour des
imbéciles
on prend les français pour des gens
extrêmement responsable extrêmement
politique personne ne peut croire que
monsieur macron va être premier ministre
il n'a pas fait le deuxième tour de la
présidentielle
il n'aura pas la majorité il ne sera pas
premier mais il raconte des
carabistouilles ses champs monsieur
mélenchon oui bien sûr et donc prendre
les gens pour des abrutis c'est pas une
manière de faire de la politique de
manière correcte nous on a expliqué les
choses parce que la logique des
institutions c'est que mes d'ailleurs ça
c'est toujours vérifier que lie à une
prime au président sortant on le sait on
ignore pas et puis on a aussi l air qui
vient en roue de secours de l erreur
donc on sait très bien que monsieur
macro aura une majorité maintenant la
question de savoir c'est ce qu'il aurait
une majorité absolue où il sera obligé
de composer avec une opposition nous
nous pensons que un pays normal doit
disposer d'une opposition une opposition
qui est ferme mais qui est aussi
respectueuse institutions et je pense
que nous incarnons cette opposition et
moi se souhaite que nous ayons le
maximum d'élus dans cette nouvelle
assemblée
alors nous avons fait
55 % marine a fait 55 % dans 87
circonscription et elle a fait plus de
50% dans 5 557 circonscription donc vous
voyez que nos perspectives
raisonnables peuvent se situer entre 87
et 157 maintenant est-ce que le mode de
scrutin est ce que la situation locale
est-ce que les
consignes un peu crapuleuses
entre-deux-tours d'appareils ne vont pas
contrarier ce scénario on regarde la
projection il faut enfin la projection
et fox et entre 20 et 45 sièges pour
leur assemblée nationale on est loin des
oui mais ça c'est l'effet du même de dia
solex et les est scandaleux du mode de
scrutin et si vous voulez on a fait la
dernière mandature marine avait fait le
deuxième tour de la présidentielle on a
fait la dernière mandature avec six
députés et on avait un sénateur c'est à
dire que sur 1000 parlementaire on avait
sept parlementaires sur 1000 alors que
nous étions la première force politique
ce n'est pas une démocratie et je pense
que un pays qui veut fonctionner
normalement avec la crise de
représentativité qu'on a eus doit avoir
une opposition qui est conséquente et
qui a les moyens d'agir avec 25 députés
nous n'avons pas les moyens par exemple
de déférer une loi ou conseil constitue
pas la preuve que la dédiabolisation n'a
pas marché sur le mode de scrutin c'est
le même pour jean luc mélenchon et les
sondages lui donnent entre 80 et 100
députés gilles pour la france en sont
issus alors jean luc mélenchon ça marche
pas bon alors je vais vous expliquer
parce que c'est c'est une question
purement électorales c'est que la gauche
qui se posent deux bastions électoraux
avec des villes imaginez que marine est
arrivé en tête dans au premier tour de
la présidentielle dans vingt mille
communes 20000 et pourtant nous avons
cette commune voyez le décalage donc
c'est cette implantation locale qui fait
qu' évidemment un dans un scrutin
majoritaire ces forces là sont avantagés
mais c'est de cet artificielle parce
qu'il ne représente pas la réalité
électorale du pays quand madame hidalgo
fait moins de 2 % aux élections et
qu'elle va avoir beaucoup plus de
députés que le rassemblement a su real
s'il ya quelque chose qui ne va pas dans
ce pays car ça parce que disait son âge
uniquement sur le groupe psa on verra on
verra mais en tout cas en tout cas il ya
quelque chose qui est totalement
déséquilibré est totalement anormale
dans n'importe quel pays d'europe nous
serions pouvoir depuis 15 ans et là nous
n'arrivons pas à avoir quelques députés
donc il faut corriger cette injustice
électorale en envoyant le maximum de
députés rn la prochaine assemblée juste
en cas de duel parce qu'il aura
forcément dans certains de ces
conceptions des duels entre la majorité
présidentielle et la france insoumise
vous donnerait des consignes de vote
voudrait bien j'avais dit oui
vous avez dire pour nous c'est pareil eh
bien ça veut dire vous verrez bien et ce
sera dès ce on n'en sait rien jeu on ne
se prononcera le soir de l'élection on
regardera les résultats on regardera la
situation politique en fonction de ça on
décidera de la position il y aura les
instances du mouvement qui se réuniront
pour décider d'une position
oui vous aviez dit il ya quelques mois
qu'eric zemmour était un concurrent est
pas un adversaire on avait bien saisi la
nuance mais après son échec à la
présidentielle et il est toujours là et
sont partis présentent des candidats
présentent même de nombreux candidats
alors est-ce qu'à vos yeux aujourd'hui
c'est toujours j'irai une saine
émulation pour votre courant politique
ou alors est-ce que ça risque pas disons
de fragmenter durablement le
rassemblement national et et disons
qu'ils sautent qui se trouve toujours en
quête de rassemblement justement non moi
je pense si vous voulez qu'il ya
toujours eu à notre marge des gens qui
se sont présentés il ya eu villiers
pendant longtemps il ya eu dupont aignan
enseignants oui on les connaît bien sûr
hélas là on à eric zemmour ça fait
partie j'allais dire du du scénario
classique c'est la marge
il est dans le camp national alors
maintenant on a beaucoup de divergences
avec lui on a des divergences notamment
sur le sur le plan économique et social
on a des divergences et social c'est ça
ce là bas pour le moins quand il vous
dit qu'il est pour la retraite entre 64
et 67 ans oui ça nous pose un problème
majeur parce que pour nous
la question de la retraite non il dit 64
ans ou plus en fait pour lui tout ça n'a
pas beaucoup d'importance pour nous
c'est un choix de société c'est un choix
important en ce qui concerne eric
zemmour je pense que il n'aura pas deux
il n'aura pas de deuxième tour
c'est une force tout à fait marginale et
moi j'invite tous les électeurs d'eric
zemmour à se porter sur un vote utile
c'est à dire le vote rassemblement
national on va regarder le sondage de la
circonscription d'eric zemmour
qui date d'hier circonscription dans le
var et il le donne devant votre candidat
le candidat du rassemblement national
philippe lottiaux qui serait donc
éliminé du deuxième tour par eric
zemmour puisque c'est la candidat de la
majorité présidentielle qui arrive en
tête ce serait un coup dur pour vous
d'être éliminé par exemple alors d'abord
les jeunes y sont pas fait parce qu'un
sondage n'est pas une élection ensuite
c'est vrai qu' à un point d'écart ou
deux points d'écart entre les deux et
que notre candidat est en train de
remonter et donc nous nous nous pensons
que nous allons être qualifiés y compris
dans cette circonscription là
nous verrons bien ah c'est pas sûr nous
verrons bien je vous ai dit nous nous
réunirons le soir du premier tour pour
voir la situation et puis pour pour
évaluer les choses mais on comprend
pourquoi
il n'a pas présenté de conti de candidat
contre marine le pen dans sa
circonscription pourquoi vous vous avez
fait le choix de présenter un candidat
contraire parce que notre candidat est
implanté depuis cinq ans que zemmour
arrive pratiquement en vacances en
chemise de plage pour faire campagne eh
bien ce n'est pas notre conception de la
politique nous pensons qu'il faut des
gens implanté qu'il faut des gens qui
qui connaissent le terrain philippe
lottiaux est un énarque c'est quelqu'un
du coin c'est quelqu'un qui s'est
présenté la dernière fois il a toute
légitimité pour représenter cette cire
quantifions tournée d'accord avec ça
chez vos jardins de garder là aussi et
était d'accord avec ça avec le fait de
ne pas présenter de candidat avec le
fait de présenter un candidat face à
eric zemmour avec le fait de ne pas
accepter la main tendue des examens oui
je vais vous expliquer pourquoi elle
fondamentalement le soir du second tour
eric zemmour prend la parole et dit
marine le pen incarne un nouvel échec et
caetera et puis je propose l'alliance
comme comme dit très justement avec
naulleau eric zemmour a inventé la tendu
dans la figure
en réalité qu'est ce qui voulait dire il
voulait dire je vais faire alliance avec
vous mais débarrassez-vous de marine le
pen or nous nous pensons qu'on a avec
marine le pen non seulement un grand
chef de parti un quelqu'un qui est
d'ailleurs le leader du camp national
naturelles y compris dans toute l'europe
mais également une femme d'état pour la
france donc les postulats d'eric zemmour
démarre assez mal si vous voulez et ce
et rendre difficile une alliance avec
lui alors après on a les divergences et
divergences sur le plan économique et
social et puis nous avons des
divergences également sur son analyse de
sur le show sur l'immigration qui nous
apparaît un petit peu raide et au sein
du rassemblement national et ce cas des
divergences on a le sentiment que la
ligne de marine le pen que vous soutenez
est une ligne qui est plus tourné vers
le pouvoir d'achat vers une ligne un peu
plus populaire que celle de jordan
bardella et plus la ligne de l'ancien
front national c'est-à-dire une ligne un
peu plus d'identité rire lord and border
line était sur france 2 et il dit si si
un congrès à l'automne si marine le pen
décide de ne pas reprendre la tête du r
n y aura un congrès et alors peut-être
une nouvelle ère s'ouvrira ça veut dire
quoi ça veut dire que voilà il ya une
nouvelle génération qui est en train de
monter moi je m'en fais moi je suis un
ancien militant du front national et du
rassemblement national et qui est des
jeunes qui montent c'est une nouvelle
ère qui s'annonce et on est
question non mais il n'y a pas de ligne
en marche sur nos deux pieds le régalien
et le quotidien le régalien c'est à la
fois la sécurité l'immigration la
restauration de l'état la place de la
france dans le monde et c'est le
quotidien c'est le pouvoir d'achat la
santé un certain nombre l'école un
certain nombre de préoccupations
immédiates des français nous nous
répondons à l'ensemble de ces
problématiques et donc je pense que non
non c'est pas il ya pas de contradiction
il ya vraiment une très grande
complémentarité je crois il ya une
vision globale de la société on va
parler de ce qui s'est passé au
parlement européen
avant-hier ouais avec effectivement un
vote une interdiction donc d'aider des
voitures neuves à partir de 2035 vous
avez voté contre c'est une opposition
aux voitures électriques ou ccc vraiment
le calendrier qui pose pas de problème
non il ya eu un vote pour interdire les
voitures thermiques à partir de 2035 la
vente la vente oui la vente ça veut dire
la production était pour nous c'est un
d'abord c'est un calendrier qui est
intenable et puis c'est un set à une
décision qui annonce une crise peut-être
même une disparition de la filière
industrielle française en ce qui
concerne l'automobile
mais bien sûr mais je vais vous dire il
ya d'abord il ya le marché européen mais
à tout le marché mondial l'afrique elle
va continuer à rouler avec des voitures
thermiques l'asie va continuer à rouler
avec des voitures thermiques et donc on
va perdre l'avantagé que nous avions
d'être d d d d
une des puissances industrielles en la
matière alors on a d'un côté les
écologistes qui nous interdisent et qui
le nucléaire et qui vise à disparition
du nucléaire notre côté et nous dit il
faut du tout électrique et là on
comprend pas et donc ils sont en train
de ruiner la filière énergétique et la
filière industrielle automobile on est
on à faire des apprentis sorciers et qui
mène notre pays à la catastrophe et on
envoie c'est pas c'est pas juste une
question de calendrier c'est pas juste
2035 c'est trop tôt c'est à dire vous
êtes contre l'interdiction totale de la
vente de voitures thermiques l'europe et
dans le monde l'europe n'est pas dans
dans dans l'univers seul il y a le monde
je peux vous dire que les coréens les
chinois ou les américains vont se
féliciter de cette de cette position qui
est une position suicidaire pour notre
industrie on va voir des centaines de
milliers d'emplois qui vont disparaître
et on fait ça en souriant comme si on
devait sauter se suicider
e
dans une partie de rigolade mais c'est
quelque chose de très sérieux qui est
arrivé qui est passée un peu sous les
radars et qui je crois devrait alerter
les gens sur la venue aux hits et de
l'union européenne mais ça veut dire
pour vous que l'industrie française même
si encore une fois elle s'y prépare mais
on comprend votre position ça passe
avant l'écologie non je pense que c'est
les progrès techniques qui fera qu' on
n'arrivera à un équilibre entre les
activités humaines et la nature depuis
2005 depuis 2005 marine le pen a demandé
le développement de la filière hydrogène
2005 nous sommes en 2022 et nous
commençons simplement la filière
hydrogène si on nous avait suivi on
serait déjà les champions du monde de
l'hydrogène est certainement on n'aurait
plus besoin de tout cela on nous a pas
suivis moi je le regrette mais on avait
une longueur d'avancé que nous nous feu
ne vous fait pas le procès de ne pas
être sur ces questions là nous sommes
sur ces questions là mais nous pensons
que il ne faut pas suivre ceux qui
pensent qu'il faut arrêter toute
activité humaine parce que les fous du
parlement européen ils interdisent la
vente de voitures thermiques très
prochainement dans moins de quinze ans
puis après ils vont interdire quoi
l'équitation le feu de cheminée le
barbecue leur vie
le feu de cheminée était était en cause
il n'y a pas très longtemps et c'est
madame ségolène royal qui à arrêter
cette folie je vous le garantis que vous
on a affaire à des gens qui sonde qui
sont vraiment très extrêmes sur ces
questions là et un autre vote et là ça a
été un rejet un peu surprise au
parlement européen d'un de la réforme du
marché carbone qui est un peu la réforme
fondamentale pour que l'union européenne
parviennent à la neutralité carbone en
la france en sont mises et les verts ont
voté contre comme vous est ce que
finalement emmanuel macron n'a pas
raison mal dans le même panier non pas
du tout je pense qu'il ya eu il ya eu un
jeu parlementaire extrêmement curieux et
je crois inédit dans cette assemblée
européenne
l'extrême gauche les écologistes et les
socialistes ont voté contre
la délibération elle
estimait que le texte n'était pas assez
ambitieux exactement et et nous pour des
raisons à verser voilà donc on peut pas
nous mettre dans le même panier et donc
qu'est ce qui s'est passé à ce moment là
les orateurs de
renault c'est à dire renaissance de
naissance la majorité présidentielle et
du dpe c'est à dire l air ont dit à la
gauche nous renvoyons aux commissions et
nous allons réexaminer tous à tous
ensemble ça signifie quoi politiquement
ça signifie que la droite et le centre
du parlement européen sont venus dire à
la gauche et l'extrême bosse nous allons
traiter ensemble et nous allons remettre
au point ce texte là ça veut dire qu'il
va revenir en étant extrêmement aggravée
vous allez obtenir l'effet inverse que
deux du coup que vous souhaitiez pardon
mais vous avez vous vous disiez le texte
il est trop ambitieux laon négociant
avec la gauche le texte il va forcément
être encore plus
ambitieux provoqué le contraire ne
tomber d'accord mais c'est pas nous qui
avons la responsabilité des textes moi
je pense que il aurait été de
2,2 bonne de bonne politique il aurait
été sa cela part de ces groupes de de
faire avec nous on a reçu un chèque qui
certes aller vers davantage d'écologie
mais de manière raisonnable plutôt que
de partir dans des délires qui sont des
délires qui vont coûter extrêmement cher
à aux ménages et à l'industrie et à
l'économie française et mme dernière
question il polit vient on dit de vous
vous êtes le principal conseiller de
marine le pen que la ligne politique
même le changement de nom du fn au grain
bien vous les avez beaucoup inspiré et
pourtant vous restez toujours discret
mais très rare sur un plateau de
télévision
ont saisi d'ailleurs avec orianne la la
rareté du dieu moment je crois que c'est
la première fois d'ailleurs que vous
venez sur ce plateau c'est une volonté
de votre part vous vous préférez
globalement l'ombre plutôt que la
lumière oui il fait plutôt quelqu'un de
discret moi j'agis avec conviction
je suis à cette fiabilité anciens de la
cause nationale
dans les faits mme amon combat de vie et
je vis avec ça évidemment de manière
publique mais je n'essaye pas d'être sur
les plateaux télévision au revoir merci
du coup d'avoir accepté notre invitation
merci beaucoup d'être venu ce matin
philippe olivier on regarde la une de la
nouvelle république que vous allez nous
expliquer avec oui oui un petit peu ce
qui sait ce qui s'est passé c'est ça ça
rebondit sur beaucoup de problèmes qui
ceux qui se posent actuellement voilà
d'aider des intrusions collège ce qui
s'est passé donc à bléré c'est en indre
et loire merci beaucoup merci dépôt
léger merci d'avoir été notre invité
[Musique]